[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es nach fünf
jahren das erste mal cake pops auf einem
kanal also ich habe die auch
zugegebenermaßen das jetzt noch vor acht
jahren gemacht aber an dieses erste mal
im trend und eigentlich hat den
einfachen grund dass mir dieser kuchen
richtig daneben gegangen ist also das
heißt daneben gegangen hat man einfach
optisch nicht so gut gefallen habe ich
den durchgeschnitten dann war die
oberste schicht zu dünn dann habe ich
mir gedacht was ist eigentlich das beste
was man daraus machen kann und cake pops
und ich mache heute eine ganz einfache
variante die jeder hinbekommen sollte
ich nehme mir dafür diesen bizkit boden
dann werde ich in der hälfte durch
teilen und dann habe ich mir gedacht
mach' ich etwas fruchtiges passend zur
jahreszeit nämlich einmal zitronen cake
pops und 1 x airbag cake pops und ich
fange direkt an ich schreibe euch
trotzdem die genauen mengenangaben auch
wenn es hier mehr nach gefühl geht unten
in die infobox und staus
tschuldigung haben sie hansa group steht
nicht einfach eine menge angaben in der
infobox der infobox
sein wichtigster part in meinen videos
soll ich nehme mir jetzt schon mal
direkt die hälfte und zerbröseln das und
dann kommt da gleich einfach lemon
körnchen verlängern könnte
[Musik]
ich habe das jetzt alles fein zerbröseln
ich werde mir auch handschuhe anziehen
weil jetzt arbeite ich für meine
zitronen cake pops mit lemon curt und
ich habe hier übrigens mein vanille
biskup boden gebacken ihr könnt
natürlich auch ein fertigkuchen neben
den simplon mal ehrlich wenn wir cake
pops machen wollen dann in der regel hat
man halt keine lust extra kuchen dafür
zu backen also durch doch gern
fertigkuchen nehmen oder kuchen den die
hat schon vorbereitet habt während wir
dann viel geworden ist oder den ihr
eingefroren haben und eigentlich denke
ich mir so okay ich mache erklärt cake
pops und dann habe ich noch eine zweite
schüssel das wäre ganz cool war mir nun
helfen würde hamzawy wer es wissen will
was willst du also es muss er schon
vorne guck mal erstmal zerbröselt tut
diesen boden muss man schon so kannst du
auch anziehen und in den boden gibt der
haben sie dann gleich dem
erdbeermarmelade hierfür und ihr könnt
auch gerne immer mit ein bisschen milch
auch nachhelfen wenn ihr mögt wichtig
ist dass die konsistenz dann
anschließend so ist dass man zeit
zusammen knetet und das team
zusammenbleibt etwas zeige ich euch
ja was auch handschuhe für
eine größe
genau einfach zerbröselt seine ganze wut
rauslassen bis zum manchmal wütend auf
mich sein oder aber
das ist fies
[Musik]
wie lange das noch heute machen wir
haben es muss richtig gefallen sein der
torso mixa wieder ganz ehrlich
chorprojekt gifte okay jetzt kann man
leider ein tor und zwei stücke mich ich
dachte ich so was macht das alles ist
schon kneten der grund sind mangelnde
reife wir müssen mit handkameras einfach
immer im laderaum zwei stücke milch oder
3 nachdem und dann zusammen knicken
einfach so dahin ja wann kommt ihr das
komisch aber nehmen die ich wohl
heute vielleicht sagen wir nicht gleich
alles auf einmal so
ich hatte halt nur so in die schüssel
getan und dann gucken wir halt immer je
nachdem was ist eine gefühlssache
auf jeden fall muss es sich halt so
kneten lassen das ist zusammen bleibt
und dann ist es eigentlich ready wir
können jetzt kugeln formen
beziehungsweise die kugel müssen halt
noch nicht so perfekt sein denn wir
müssen das ganze gleich nochmal einen
kühlschrank bezugs ins gefrierfach
stellen und ich nehme jetzt dafür meine
waage und jedes cake pops wird bei mir
so ungefähr circa 30 gramm schwer sein
unseres machen also dass sie noch so zu
gruselig aus zeigt man also ich solche
hast du will muss mal so richtig ja
genau 8 uhr ruhig die restlichen
und genau und die mich
ja
nicht an seinem zu machen ja schön sehen
sein
die
kosten nochmals lade ich glaube ich
jetzt nicht das aber kann man das muss
auch sehen wie bei mir ja das macht doch
mal richtig zu greifen richtig rein
ja ja genau
okay ich hab jetzt immer eine
planänderung rohform sitzt die kugel
ist gut aus du hast ja nein das sieht
gut aus das ist echt nur
dummes diesen teil
und sticht immer 25 gramm ab und freut
sich zu einer kugel am taxi denn hierhin
haben sie weißt du was viele immer
fragen wie ist es eigentlich so mit
deiner frau zusammen zu arbeiten so geht
es nicht irgendwann so auf die senke das
ist eine frage wie sollte man eine für
dax band ordentlich wieso dann noch
ehrlich wenn kein geheimnis ist völlig
natürlich nicht mit diesem motto und
andere fragen auch habt ihr nicht immer
was zu bereden also gebt euch das
gesprächsthema war hausfrau für ein
mögliches kitchen bist dann hast du was
habe ich immer was es nie diese diese
unangenehme stille dass man so denkt ist
auch kein gesprächsthema
[Musik]
also - grad noch eingefallen beziehen
sich auf den einfall dass ich in die
hälfte meines fttx noch getrocknete
früchte reim machen könnte erdbeer nehme
ich hab mir gerade zum beispiel
himbeeren da und die kriege ich jetzt
einfach noch in den teig 1 das macht
immer alles schöner und die schmecken
extrem fruchtig
[Musik]
haben wir ja komm mach dein kräfte
okay kam jetzt auf traditionelle art und
weise habe ich immer
ladengeschäft war das ist ganz toll sehr
toll abo unter der wir niemals auf dem
stuhl halten wenn der vom stil her dann
waren kürzungen ja du kannst ja auch mit
kleineren machen kannst du eben nichts
dran rom gewonnen unser gewissen technik
wäre ja du musst deinen das anspannen
oder so machen ok
yahoo a
ha
wunderschön doch richtig bitter
vernaschen du kannst ja von unten aus
sprich muss ich schon gesagt das thema
kommt ja ich bezweifle ist so ich hoffe
ich habe sie gut geholfen das was das
war gut gibt denn eins plus mit
sternchen und wir haben viel zeit
eingespart aus einem minus von chatter
ist eins von zehn oder
also ich werde die cake pops jetzt
einfrieren wenn ihr zeit habt könnt ihr
sie in den kühlschrank legen für zwei
bis drei stunden ich mach das mal auf
die schnelle art und weise und gibt sie
für 40 minuten ins gefrierfach
für die cake pops sind jetzt schön durch
gekühlt bzw sind schon mal so kühl dass
man sie dass man sie einmal zur
richtigen kugeln formen kann genau denn
vorher waren wir noch ein bisschen krumm
und schief und ich habe mir jetzt auch
schon ein bisschen weiße kuvertüre und
freue mich kuvertüre in der mikrowelle
geschmolzen und das müssen wir noch die
cake pops stille da reinstecken damit
sie besser halten müsst euch jetzt im
vorfeld überlegen welche färbte später
weiß und welche in vollmilch schokolade
ein ich mache jetzt die zitronen cake
pops mit weißer schokolade sind weg
ouvertüre einmal in die kuvertüre rein
und dann zur hälfte in die cake pops
reinstecken
[Musik]
das wasser ist bei mir schon ein mal
aufgekocht ist hab ich den herd auch
schon wieder aus und lasst zwei drittel
über dem wasserbad schmelzen und sobald
es dann geschmolzen ist gebiet das
letzte drittel dazu und damit verhindern
wir einfach einen grauschleier und die
schokolade ist einfach viel hübscher und
glänzender jetzt wird's richtig spaß ich
denn jetzt werden die gefrorenen cake
pops in die kuvertüre getunkt ich mache
jetzt einmal diese app der cake pops die
gebe ich jetzt in die voll mit kuvertüre
kurz rein und dann sehr gut abtropfen
lassen und das gute ist dadurch dass sie
gefroren sind hält der stil auch
bombenfest damit hätte ich früher immer
ein problem das ich immer ungeduldig war
und dem abgefallen ist und ich nehme
jetzt zur deko gefriergetrocknete
früchte ihr dürft ihr jetzt natürlich
alles nehmen was ihr möchtet häuser
würden auch ganz gut passen aber ich
glaube auch der fruchtige ebene heute
und jetzt könnt ihr die einfach irgendwo
aufstellen ich habe jetzt extra dafür
ein cache pop spender aber ihr könnt
auch zb das mache ich gleich auch mal
ihr könnt auch ein glas mit reis nehmen
oder ein glas mit zucker noch besser
glaube ich sogar und dann könnte es auch
da rein tun das mache ich jetzt auch
direkt
natürlich kann man in zucker danach
wieder zurück packen der wird ja nicht
schmutzig
[Musik]
ich finde dass wir richtig elegant aus
jetzt einmal hier rein und es steht wie
mir eins also braucht ihr gar keinen
cake pops ständer sondern können sich
einfach so ein glas mit zucker nehmen
[Musik]
hamza
er ist so ein langsamer so wir machen
jetzt im test
wir haben einmal
ja einmal hier erdbeer und eleven card
was mich das auch so hier ein budget
jordanier kräfte bislang über das dass
ein locker so 33 cake pops in allem also
ein start wäre heben und ist einfach
auffällt ist also schon erstmal der
schoko oder nämlich dann abgehängt
stürmte aber das ist richtig schön es
ist ganz toll dass sie keine
temperierten kuvertüre wenn man die
nicht temperieren würde dann wäre das
wirklich nicht so schön glänzen so genau
was auch immer temporären bedeutet 100
mein video gehört aber ich weiß ja sagen
heftig aus richtig hinaus nicht nur mit
den händen ich will
das sieht aus wie gesunde wie so ein
edel schoko
manchmal sehr frisch schmecken lernen
gehört richtig raus über dir
erdbeermarmelade schmeckt es direkt
drauf aber die schule simuliert schon
also die schon sehr dominant den jahren
das stimmt aber ich finde auch ich finde
auch die kombination lecker dann ist es
nicht mehr einfach so ein
klumpen also dadurch habe er auch
getrocknete früchte rein gemacht und
dabei ist dann halt auch draußen das
finde ich auch richtig lecker dabei
scheint das auch so allgemein so kommt
ihr schmeckt gut und ich glaube 34 stück
davon kann ich in solcher verdrücken
also immer merken einfach dabei um
schütze ist es war das meiste schon
geboxt habe ich schon damals da waren
profis am werk ohne witz und ich bin
echt hammer ich hoffe dass wir auch mal
kleine schwester probiert weil wieder da
also macht gerne nach hause möchte
schuldig
während hamburg dass das coole ist am
sonntag bei uns auch was besonderes an
denn meine schwester wird heiraten und
wir sind für dieses treffen zum beispiel
könnt ihr das ganz schön
anbieten oder bei verlobungsparty
es intensiver weise viel dicker ist drei
mal so viel in der opposition ist wächst
du bist du hast ja jetzt lernen wir ja
ich finde das mit lämmern karte ist auch
mein oberster boss gut wie perfekt sie
also jetzt kann zu weiteren schon
gerochen ich habe mich gar nicht
mitzuziehen außer dass es wirklich zu
ganz vielen anlässen machen könnt und
das ist auch was es nun zusammen machen
kann
dann ganz viel spaß und nachmachen
wir werden uns jetzt auf jeden fall und
wünschen euch noch einen wunderschönen
tag
[Musik]